listen don't wait for permission from
your husband from your parents from your
children from anyone remember god gave
it to you not them the universe gave it
to you not them you see i really believe
sometimes our subconscious is really
powerful it's like this powerhouse
computer and when things don't go right
it says it's not your fault your
husband's not all in with you it's not
your fault inflation is here it's not
your fault we have covid it's our fault
we have shutdowns and all i know is if
you have a millimeter a crumb of you
saying i could do this but if there's
any but that means you're not taking
complete ownership even if someone else
lets you down even if the partner robs
all your money even if your spouse
cheated on you i get that a lot of you
are here for a lot of different reasons
money health life passion what if you
just took complete ownership i made this
mistake i waited too long i accepted
this i'm not saying it's right but
here's what i want to tell you when you
decide that it's all on you oh my god
it's so liberating because then it's all
on you if it wins that's you if it
doesn't win that's you need motivation
watch a top 10 with believe nation hey
it's evan carmichael and i make these
videos because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best dean graziosi and my take on
his top 10 rules of success enjoy
[Music]
what if we decided to take ownership
of all of it what do you think is the
most costly advice in the world it's
your broke friend
telling you how to get rich it's your
single friend telling you what you
should do with your relationship we are
letting
unqualified people
tell us where our future should be be
and the way i look at it is
i don't want anybody steering my ship if
something pops in your head and go
damn
i'm letting him i'm letting her i'm
letting that thought
steer my ship
listen at the end of our lives
let's just again i
i digress a little bit but i want to
anchor each one of these things at the
end of our lives
if you have a chance to meet with god
meet with your maker whatever you
believe that is
do you want to give excuses on why it
didn't work because you listened to
other people my mom said that wouldn't
work my husband thought that was a crazy
idea my cousin diane said you know you
need money to make money or that men are
evil and once they cheat every man
cheats or every man's bad like i don't
know what that is
but would you would you hate to be at
the end of your life and realize that
you missed out on love
you missed out on connection missed out
on that business because you took bad
advice
i always think about this
i i do these little tricks
that maybe you think are mean but i
always think of if you met your maker at
the end of your life imagine if god
pulled out his iphone because of course
he's got an iphone imagine god pulled
out his iphone and played you a video
of the woman or man you could have been
think about that one for a minute
imagine seeing the three-minute
highlight reel of the love you could
have had
the health you could have enjoyed
the impact you could have made on the
world
man i think about that and it just
freaking like hell no it's go time and
will we fail of course but i would so
much rather be on the field playing and
failing than being in the sidelines
wearing someone else's jersey on the
back of my shirt i am not putting out
someone else's name on my jersey it's
graziosi on the back and i'm in the game
and that's in the game of life rule
number two be congruent there's nothing
more powerful
than congruency
to reach your full potential to have
confidence to be courageous
you know listen
we all have friends that say they want
the passion back in their relationship
do we does anybody here have a friend
that would love passion or a connection
back in a relationship a friend that
tells you
anybody have a friend that tells you
they want passion or connection in their
relationship
but there's they're on facebook looking
up old high school boyfriends or
girlfriends dm'ing people when nobody's
knowing i know a couple people in my
life that say they want in front stage
they want the connection they want to
love again but when no one's watching
they're kind of doing the stuff that
derails that
people who say they want to be in the
best shape of their life this is the
year i want to be healthy my kids
deserve me to be healthy but when no
one's watching they skip the workout or
they go to the gym but they sit on their
phone the whole time and when they
should order something a little
healthier they order the something they
shouldn't order but when no one's
watching it's no big deal right and then
they're telling their friends at lunch i
just don't know why the weight won't
come off i'm in the gym five days a week
i'm eating so great bs you're not doing
the work when no one's watching
right you say you want that business to
thrive to go to another level but you
did all the easy parts and now you got
to dig into marketing you got to let
your friends know you're going in this
business it's a little uncomfortable so
when no one's watching you're working on
your logo or the name of your site
rather than the marketing that actually
gets you out there or the phone call you
need to make to close the deal but you
tell your friends it's not working but
really you're not doing the work you
should be doing when no one's watching
you guys feeling me on this one
congruency is so unbelievable and that's
where values come from that's where
character comes from i am by far not
saying i'm perfect in any shape way or
form but i have an obsession now
especially at this phase of my life i
want to be so congruent that if my
my my wife my kids put a hidden camera
on me for a week and they watch it like
damn he does the same stuff he talks
about
i would love for you guys to see me at a
restaurant having a conversation with my
family you're in the booth behind me and
you don't know that i'm i don't know
you're there and you get done go damn
that's the same guy i met when we were
on camera
that is so powerful and the reason it's
the theme for my kids is listen 15 or 13
who has kids
right raise your hand if you have
children in today's world can they
pretty much do anything they want on
social i mean they could be online they
could find porn in two minutes they
could do a million things they at 15 i
know my my daughter has friends that
already drink already do some other
stuff right they could and they could
lie about all of it turn off their
locations and figure it out i have to
train my kids that not train give them
the ability to understand is who you are
when no one's watching is who you really
are i said you could act perfect in
front of me perfect in front of your
teachers but if you're doing the things
when no one's watching then that's you
god the universe your character
and and
my kids are far from perfect but they
understand core values because of that
so today i'm taking a little longer as
we start here this morning i want to
share with you that that could be a
theme or come up with your own 2022
theme but i want to do the work when i
think about that when no one's around i
want to do the work to be a bet i when
no one was watching for four days
straight i obsessed on what i was going
to teach you today it'll seem really
easy thing like it's just coming off my
tongue i have this whole thing laid out
to get you the results you deserve you
desire right i did the work when no
one's watching so now when i'm front
stage it looks easy looks amazing but i
really got my own notes and cheat sheet
here my daughter and son both pitch they
love winning games
you don't win on stage you know when you
win you win when you're my daughter and
son are out back at 4 30 today my
daughter will be with her pitching coach
and she'll pitch for two hours she'll
pitch until her arm hurts she does that
on a regular basis but when she goes and
wins a game
it's because of what she did once no
one's watching so did you ever hear that
uh that
joke it's a a gambler non a gambler who
gambles nonstop passes away he wakes up
and all of a sudden he's in a casino
he's dressed to the nines and every time
he walks up to a slot machine he puts in
money
and he pulls the handle and money comes
out he's like oh my god i won he goes to
another and puts money and pulls the
handle oh my god i won and he keeps
going and all of a sudden he puts money
in he's just winning every time he puts
money and he's winning every time
finally he's got this big bucket of
quarters or money and he walks up to one
of the you know the people dressed nice
and he's like oh my god he said
i didn't think heaven would be like this
and the guy looked at him and said who
said you're in heaven
you see we all think we want it easy we
all think we just want the
we want to open the gates and all the
money and the happiness and the joy just
pour out why when people hit lotto do
they go broke
because they had the resources handed
them but handed to them but they never
found a way to be resource fault
you see how we get resourceful is
actually understanding that problems are
the path to our bigger future so if we
handle bigger problems we get bigger
results rule number three focus on
relationships even if you're in a career
and you're in a job that you like or
you're gonna start a business or you're
in a business
this is a time when people are uncertain
we must serve more give more if you have
a product make it better if you do
customer support improve the customer
support i'm telling you in times like
this the winners are the people that
create now once you hear the difference
what companies will go out of business
are companies that are based on
transactions only
companies that will go out of business
are based on transactions only compared
to based on relationships be a
relationship business owner be a
relationship marketer be in relationship
when you sell no matter what your
product is no matter what your services
when you are a relationship focused
company or individual in your company
and you want to raise go up the ladder
of your career when you focus on
relationships when you focus on
listening to others understanding where
people are rather than just
transactional things change forever
michael gerber's book ages ago i
remember and i'm going to paraphrase i
read that book a decade or more ago
is i remember saying do you know what
the difference between doctors being
sued and not for malpractice
anybody remember that in michael
gerber's book it was ages ago i read it
you know what the difference was
eight minutes
doctors who spent 10 minutes or less
with a client
were way more likely to be sued than
doctors who spent 18 minutes or more
the only determining factor was a
relationship because they come into your
room
doctor comes in if you're a relationship
how you doing you're not feeling so good
you got a temperature oh i think it's i
think it's this that and the other thing
okay take care and you're out
that's just a guy another guy comes it's
oh my god isabel how's your daughter
doing did she went off to college right
oh that's good she did she like in
college great and they have a
communication 18 minutes compared to 10
is the difference between a malpractice
lawsuit or not
so if you're in business have a career
want to expand this is the year to serve
more love more go deeper what has
hesitation
already cost you
your family doesn't need you to hesitate
your family needs you to be bold the
world needs you to be bold
because at the end of the day
remember what i said earlier about that
conversation with your maker would you
rather say i hesitated i was a little
nervous i waited
or would you rather say
i went forward even though i was scared
to death and i failed for a while which
one would you rather choose would you
rather choose trying and failing
or hesitation in nothing
hesitation in nothing or trying and
failing because if you try and fail what
are you going to do next you're going to
try again and if you fail what are you
going to do you're going to try again
and with lauren what are you going to do
after that i know tony robbins does this
and i love it you're going to try it
again
and there's no way if you continue
trying there's no way you don't get to
the finish line it's impossible those
that don't get to the finish line just
found a certain place where they say
enough i'm not going to try anymore i'm
going to sit right here and what happens
five years goes by just like that rule
number four build yourself first when
somebody tells me money doesn't buy
happiness i'm sorry i'm going to say one
bad word today [ __ ]
[ __ ]
money can serve in such a great way
money is bad when people do bad things
with it money can be amazing when you do
the right thing what i'm telling you
today this is not what i thought i was
going to share put your oxygen mask on
first
that's what you need to do you need to
take uncomfortable action you need to
push yourself if you're a part of our
mastermind family welcome be here push
yourself
stop waiting for someone else to do it
take uncomfortable action do the things
you need to do even if it's at your own
pace you don't have to be
roger rabbit going 100 miles an hour but
you got to move forward don't wait no
one's coming to do this for you whatever
you have whatever capabilities whatever
part of our company you are or anything
you're doing if you really want to make
a difference
if you want to be in that place where
you can have your oxygen mask on first
i'm gonna be really honest with you
it's not easy
i've doubted myself a million times
i felt like an imposter a million times
i've had my own family look me in the
eye and say stop being a dreamer dean
that's for other people you didn't go to
college we don't come from that kind of
money you'll never be that
they don't say that when i land my own
jet in my hometown and my whole family
gets off my own plane right i don't say
that to be a jerk i don't you don't even
see me do you ever see me post a picture
of my plane on my instagram i'm not the
guy that holds up money or shows you in
my plane
or my house that's
the house of my dreams i don't do that
i don't want people to follow me because
i hold stacks of money on a on a
facebook ad
right i want people to know me for the
heart i have
but i'm blessed to have more success
than i ever could a dream possible and i
get to take care of the people i love i
got to put my own oxygen mask on years
ago and now i put it on a lot more
people than you'd ever know that's not
all i donate to
we've done it in a lot of different
areas and this year i want to donate i
don't know about the feelings you have
but who
who felt that in their heart when i
shared what i was able to do
right who in here has a desire to help
other people once you're secure
can i give can i share something with
you
and i want to share this today because
it just feels on my heart
i'm going to tell you to be selfish
be selfish
be selfish for the next three years
go get yourself strong go put your own
oxygen mask on
put some money in the bank
crush your company be selfish with your
time
be selfish with your income be greedy on
the amount of money you want to make i'm
telling you be greedy be selfish you
know why because if you go all in if you
stop thinking i wish i could do more be
more
go all in and make the money
get secure and put your oxygen mask on
and what you can do in five years from
now what you can do in seven years from
now what you could do in 12 years from
now is unbelievable but we need this
moment of us
we need this moment of getting ourselves
so many of us so many of you i see right
now are the most giving people you've
ever any anyone knows you're the person
that gives the most you know what you're
doing you're putting oxygen masks on
everybody else and you can barely
breathe
you're out there helping everybody let's
do this let's do this let's do this and
you're barely breathing you're like
here's an oxygen mask here's an oxygen
mask when you need to hold it to your
face
i love the story of andrew carnegie
right what did andrew carney get a
certain pace of his life you know what
he said i'm going to spend half the
first half of my life making a ton of
money
and i'm going to send spend the second
half of my life
giving it all away
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five improve your
communication skills i want to tell you
i saw
because i obsess on communication
because i know my wife because i love
being in love i love the fact that my
wife still looks at me every morning
like it's the first week we met it is
the most magical thing i could ever
share with anyone i walk in a room if my
wife looks at me she looks at me a way
that
takes my knees out she still looks at me
like i'm
the greatest human she's ever seen and i
feel so blessed and it just makes me
mirror that back to her
but i'm gonna tell you a little
something
my wife's a badass she had her own
business when i met her she was voted
the top hair stylist in arizona eight
out of ten years she has her own
business right next door
it's not easy being married to me
because i am like a steamroller and life
kind of because my business has gotten
so big and my schedule is so nuts a lot
of life has to revolve around me
i hate to say it but it's true it's i
travel a lot i have to go and speak i
have i'm partners with tony my partner
tony robbins i help also run tony's
company and the company we own together
and my own company and i own over 100
different houses and i have a real
estate division and i'm writing a new
book end and end and i want to be a good
dad to my older children and and
man a lot of life revolves around me so
you marry a powerful amazing woman who's
used to having her freedom control of
her time control of her business control
of everything and all of a sudden you
marry a man who's like
you're like hey i gotta be it's like no
no babe we're jumping on a plane i gotta
deal the clothes in malibu and or i
gotta go to down to florida and talk to
tony and i want to tell you my wife's
business is amazing
but in comparison my wife has a great
year it could be hundreds and hundreds
of thousands i have a great year it's
tens of millions of dollars so there's
sometimes i'm being really personal i
want to tell you how like why
communication is so important she could
say hey babe but i was going to do this
thing and i in my head i'm like
you're going to do a 500 hair extension
thing that you want to do i'm going to
close a 20 million deal scrap that get
on the plane we're out of here right
those are some of the things i know i
did in previous relationships mine's
bigger mine's more important it's about
me be happy we're wealthy you get to
have freedom jump on the plane do what
the hell i say can you see how as a guy
that's easy to just say i got this i'm
working i got this hunt don't worry you
never have to work again close your shop
close it down we don't need it
that's how
my my
previous self thought of things just
being honest this is how we grow
but now i have to think about that all
the time and i make compromises and i
communicate with her in a way babe what
you did is absolutely amazing and if you
want me to shift that i'll move my
meeting and we adjust and we communicate
and she'll have the nerve to come to me
and say babe all last month it was all
about you can i work on a little bit
like oh my god did i do that to you all
right tell me and we'll communicate and
we'll talk i want to tell you in my 30s
it would have been like
uh
mind is multi-millionaire yours is
peanuts my way or the highway without
even realizing i was saying that can you
guys understand i'm not a bad human i
didn't ever think i was doing i thought
i was working hard for my family it's
like i'm talking about leaving legacy i
want to make sure my children and my
dream children and my
great-grandchildren are protected and i
have you guys to worry about in my
project next family and self-education
family and my partnerships i have so
much to worry about it's me
how do you think my relationship would
be with my wife if it was all about me
how do you think it would be when i
walked in a room if i squashed her
dreams and her desires and just made it
all about me and didn't communicate i'm
just telling you
the communication skills you think you
have right now that are good they could
be better because if you would have
asked me in my 40s about if i was a good
communicator i would have said one of
the best in the world because i can
close deals great i also went through a
divorce in my 40s
how good of a communicator was i rule
number six keep on going life can pull
us in a lot of directions the craziness
of the outside world can allow us to
forget about our dreams or
find imposter syndrome or lose our
confidence lose our drive lose our
desire lose our focus we get overwhelmed
on not knowing where to start and then
we don't start at all
all those things happen their life
add in two and a half years of covid
now at that we're going into an economic
winter and inflation high which is gas
and food and all the prices are high we
add that we're in a polarized time in
history where it feels like everybody's
trying to push us apart when we're
trying to come back together anybody
feel that way wouldn't we rather all
just get together and find our common
ground the media and the world want to
tell us how different we are but i think
we have way more in common
than everybody's telling us and if we
all were exactly the same wouldn't that
just be a boring world right
so we're in this time of
of a couple of two and a half years of
of of covid and then we go into a place
where there's now we're in an economic
downturn
um recession
looming i think by july 1 they'll
officially announce we're in a recession
if you ask somebody we're actually in it
and i was in business for myself in 2009
or in
2007 we went to a recession but i was
also in business for myself in 1999 who
remembers the the internet crash right
of 99. i was in business then as well
naive and didn't even know it was a
thing by 2007 i understood it more and
had smarter friends and we made
transitions and shifts in advance so we
were able to thrive through that
shifting time if i was just starting in
business if i wanted to shift my life
my income my success my happiness my joy
what would i like to learn
so that's really i'd love to say that
there's more thought to it than that we
need this connection we need to be
plugged in we need not to forget what
our dreams are we need not to let
imposter syndrome
be in control of us we can't let the
inner self doubt say play small
especially now with the world shifting i
just want to tell you
this is not a time to
sit on your hands
i did an interview uh two or three days
ago with tom bilyeu i don't know if
anybody any of you have ever seen uh
impact theory with tom bilyeu on youtube
he's really good dear friend he's great
he interviews wonderful people he's
really smart so i took my kids with me i
had a couple podcasts i went and saw my
friend brennan burchard and then i flew
down to go see tom bilyeu and i brought
my older kids my 13 and 15 year old and
let them see what what their dad does
i'll tell you a story about that in a
minute
um
and as i'm as i was talking with tom
and talking about where the world is
going and the shifts happening i'm going
to use the real estate space as an
example when the economy shifts
interest rates went up 0.75 all of these
things affect and and if you're old
enough to understand there's a bigger
by-product coming right the housing
industry there's no way it can't be
affected it's coming right
but when you're in an industry that's
been booming for 10 or 12 years and if
you're in the mortgage industry or the
housing if you sell houses if you build
houses if you build a part like if
you're in it
the last thing you want to do is it face
it go no maybe it's a little hiccup oh
this will happen quick right and we get
a little amnesia up to the way it used
to be so instead of saying no no it's
going to be fine
if i truly care about you guys what i
want to do today is help prepare you
help anticipate not make it worse than
it is but not make it better than it is
you know when things change
when it's scary when something new
happens
what does we always talk about we flight
or fight right we got the flight or
fight mechanism tom biliu said something
i never heard he said the third f
he thinks is
even more relevant in today's world and
that's freeze
that's freeze that's what i want you to
think about today that was my notes here
my team puts together nice cheat sheets
for me and i write all over them so much
and so sloppy i can't read my own
writing but what i wrote was the three
f's fight flight or freeze
with all the crap that's led up to this
recession this inflation of two and a
half years of covid where covet did
things like made us realize screw that
job of me going in every day
and not being with my family not doing
something i love being unsure missing
like screw that i'm out on that 82
percent of people right now want to quit
or leave their job to do something new
or do their own thing
never before has it been the worst it
was ever prior to this was 48
and that was a couple decades ago so 82
percent of people are like covid made me
realize maybe you went through a little
hardship but with that shift
comes uncertainty right and then all of
a sudden you slam into gas the highest
it was and inflation and now you're like
should i not buy my house should i wait
to buy should i wait to sell should i
what should i do should i invest should
i take my money out of the stock market
is my 401k gonna go away forever should
it go back today take it out and sit in
cash but if i do that they say cash is
trash so if i sit on cash it's trash but
if i leave it in the market it goes down
ah
right and all of a sudden this
uncertainty builds and if uncertainty
builds
more than i've seen in my 53 years on
this planet
guess what happens
freeze
i don't know if i should do my
self-education industry i don't know if
i should
do anything with investment i don't know
and when you when you feel that way you
freeze you sit on your hands you do
nothing this is not a time to freeze in
fact this is a time
to thrive
this is a time to gain capabilities
because most people are going to freeze
more than you know and we're not there
yet
if people smarter than me where we're
going with i get the chance to have
great conversations
more and more uncertainty will climb
confidence will go down and more and
more freezing will happen rule number
seven
believe
it's the power of
you can't
i really want you to hear hear this
because i this is stuff i've already
taught you or you've probably already
heard but i want to give you some catch
phrases i want to give you some catch
phrases that you go oh
i get that right
anybody here listen to matthew
mcconaughey's book green lights raise
your hand if you did
such a good book oh my god any i don't
know if you listen to it but he's like
you know he's an actor and he's a
storyteller and
he's one crazy dude and way crazier than
you thought and and really a
good dude like because he's evolved and
he grew uh good family man all that
stuff but the whole point the name of
the book is green lights
and
his whole point the green light is in
life when things go sideways and this
didn't happen someone lets you down
right the tony robbins life happens for
us not to us a lot of times when it was
something that went totally sideways or
he gets stuck with a a foster family
that is absolutely insane in australia
and he can't leave for a year and he's
going crazy all these things that he
thought were like the end of his life a
red light
when he looked back there were actually
a green light wow that gave me the gift
to understand this it gave me the
ability to act gave me the ability to
understand that trouble with my dad made
me a better human here that trouble my
mom made me a better husband right and
all those things and he just he anchored
that when something's going sideways in
most cases
it's a green light and throughout the
book i'm not going to try to pretend to
talk like matthew mcconaughey but
through the book you know he gets to a
point and all of a sudden he goes
green light
and now in my head
the reason i'm sharing this because i
want to talk about the power if you
can't is i love little things like that
because you're going through a tough
time like damn why is this happening and
all of a sudden your brain goes green
light you're like oh
all right
just like that green light phrase i want
you to think of you can't as a new
trigger of like oh yes i can
you see i've embodied that
when you think hey i'm going to launch
my knowledge industry my self-education
i want to launch my course my coaching
program my high ticket offer
i'm going to launch my next level online
business
during a recession
and people in your family are going to
go oh you can't do that
friends are going to say oh you can't do
some of that now
say you can't do it during this
presidency or you can't do it over the
last presidency you can't do it over the
next one
and then what happens is
your inner self-doubt if you guys ever
read millionaire success habits i call
it the inner villain will say
you can't do this you've tried before
you're too old
too young
you don't understand technology you're
an introvert
all these things happen and that voice
goes you can't you can't and here's
what's so sad the majority of the world
go
yeah maybe i can't
but what i've trained myself to do it's
why i wrote it in that book and why i'm
going to give you this little thing
today is when that voice comes in your
ear or someone says it to you or it
comes from inside you can't means i must
right when i look back god i was so
lucky because i didn't have a lot of
mentors when i was younger but i
remember family and friends telling me
my i can't and i remember thinking in my
head they're right i don't have money
not that smart i've never done this
before
but who the heck no way i must now
right my my 12th grade yearbook my my
saying was like no one knows me now but
you'll hear me someday and it was that
same philosophy i don't know where i got
it from maybe it's watching my mom's
struggle and i wanted to take care of
her but i just remember everybody saying
you're not that smart if you're not
going to college if you're not doing
this if you don't have money it takes
money to make money
my guidance counselor literally and
maybe you guys can appreciate someone
who said this in your life at one point
my guidance counselor literally told me
not exaggerating i'm not making this up
that i should go if i wasn't going to
college that i should go to the only
factory in our town
and start
with a minimum wage job packing plastic
bags in boxes they were a plastic bag
company and she said you might be able
to work your way up through that
thanks ms canosa i'm glad you saw my
potential we've all been there it's like
really it was like college ah
oh the dumb guy oh you know go pack
minimum wage maybe you could be a line
manager someday i mean literally come on
but the reason i'm saying this is
because eddie
somewhere
someone told you can we just say it like
it is
sometime in your life maybe multiple
times
someone told you you can't
or that's not for you or it's not the
right time
or that's for other people and you
didn't do
it i could get emotional i don't know
what maybe because i'm not feeling good
i could literally cry
i'm not kidding because
how many times have you missed out on
the man or the woman you're supposed to
be
because someone unqualified told you you
should and the only reason i think i get
emotional is because i was a millimeter
away from not being this guy
i was a millimeter away from believing
what everybody told me
you don't have great grades you don't
have money
you're not going to college you should
just be happy with the life that
someone else deals with you
or dealt you rule number eight surround
yourself with greatness hear me on that
you must who we surround ourselves is
who we become
that's not my saying that's been around
since the beginning of time
it's a fact
so who will you listen to learn from
and who will you be persuaded by
find those
that are living life where you want to
live
and model it
listen i'm not talking listen
today i'm sharing what i've learned over
30 years of going after it i've failed
miserably i've had an ulcer in my life i
went through a divorce i've had panic
attacks i've had anxiety attacks i went
broke once all the way down to nothing
how to sell the house i was living in
but i've also found real love in my life
i don't if if you guys follow me on
instagram my wife and i don't have an
instagram relationship i'm married to
the love of my life i fall more in love
every day my wife's here today when she
came in today i i see her it's five
years we've been together she walks in a
room i feel like i'm 12 years old and
i'm in love with my best friend i love
being a dad i i live in the house of my
dreams i get to fly on my own plane i
get to do all this cool stuff i have 15
different companies but
and
and
last year we fed 7 million people
through feeding america last year we
built two
schools in africa last year i donated
600 000 of my own money to help kids in
slavery through operation underground
railroad and that's only some of the
things we've done
i don't say that to brag i say that
because that was a kid who lived in a
trailer park
who
lived in a bathroom with his dad who
didn't go past high school who got made
fun of who had parents who struggled
terribly i'm not saying look what i've
done magic i'm just saying what's
possible when you shift the outcome when
you decide to follow people who've
already done it model people that if you
want to play great tennis i don't care
if your aunt edna watched every tennis
match for the last 40 years if she's
never played never won never failed you
can't take advice from aunt edna you
could give her a kiss and bring her some
flowers and go find someone who used to
play tennis or plays tennis better than
you and let them raise your bar raise
your bar raise your standards raise what
you're willing to accept for yourself
and for your family rule number nine
focus on the fix
how many people in your life you know
are still stuck on the thing that went
wrong they started the business started
a real estate business in 06 and then
the economy shifted that burned him
never again will i go in business had a
relationship in 2014 and that bastard
cheated on me never again with men
they're all pigs
right
which a lot of them are i get it i'm not
sticking up for bad men or anyone bad
right my whole point is sometimes when
things go sideways we focus on why the
hell it happened how could he do that we
started that partnership and he robbed
the money we started doing business
together and she didn't stick to her
she didn't stick to her you know what
she promised and what happens is our
brain wants to focus on why it happened
whose fault and it could happen again
you can't succeed that way
you have to train your brain to say that
sucks and i'm sorry if any of those
things happen to you
but what did i learn from it and i gotta
move on i gotta focus on solutions what
i taught my kid my son brody needs this
help more than any anybody and i remind
them all the time i call it focus on the
fix when something goes off with my son
he really wants to analyze it and think
about it and and like almost get sad
over it and i'm trying to slowly and
through the years he's 13 now and he's
way better is focus on the fix it
happened
it went sideways like i know this sounds
crazy but it's like if you spill a glass
of milk you could say damn why did that
spill somebody put it on the carpet it's
older milk it's going to get in it's
going to make make it smell why would
someone put it there is the floor uneven
you can do all those things or you can
go get a towel and a new glass of milk
when people let you down it goes
sideways and what if
that failure is nothing more than
something you needed so you could be
stronger
have you ever met anybody super
successful that didn't go through hell
to get there
i haven't have you ever met anybody with
an amazing
incredible love passion-filled
relationship that didn't go through hell
prior
i don't know or didn't go through some
tough times to figure it out i am
married to the love of my life i do have
the best relationship of
i mean it's unbelievable i have but i
also messed up a previous relationship
and felt pain and went through a divorce
i had to go through that to figure that
out i'm sorry i had to i
hope so many of you didn't have to but i
did it's the same thing here what if
that problem that that thing that went
wrong the spilled milk is just part of
your puzzle pieces
and paraphrasing and taking from my
friend tony is what if life happened for
us
not to us remember the little things are
the big things and what do i mean by
that we set these big resolutions but
what we're doing today is we're going
upstream to anchor in all these little
knobs these little you know they say uh
small hinges swing a big door what we're
talking about these bullet points that
i'm giving you today every thank you
diane for writing that down the little
things are the big things
that's all i'm giving you these little
ships that you go oh that i can't
believe that you know what i'm gonna
focus on how to fix this what can i
learn from it and how can i can i fix it
you know something happens you go ah you
know i'll wait you know
i've hesitated in the past i'm not gonna
hesitate anymore i'm gonna be bold i'm
gonna do it anyway i'm gonna do it
anyway right these little things are the
big things so the reason i did that is
what routines
what disciplines
what morning routines what focus time do
you need
what creative time do you need
what prac practicing personal growth
listening to it
setting yourself up daily for a win what
little things can you do that move the
needle in a big way right what is the
art of kaizen
how do you run a thousand mile race one
step at a time how do you make your
goals stick in 2022 one little piece at
a time what little routines can you
shift what morning habits can you shift
and rule number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips is make an
impact make an impact
and that's what i consider being success
success isn't just the money you know i
have to tell you and do you mind if i
share i hope i hope you don't think i'm
bragging i don't tell anybody i don't
take pictures
but 10 years ago 10 or 12 years ago i
got invited by somebody now maybe 15
years ago i got invited
to go on a private plane
i don't know i honestly don't know how
long ago it could have been 20 years ago
and it was something that was really
wealthy
and i was i i'm like i came from a kid
it was in a trailer park and i was
already in business i was already doing
well but nothing like that and i flew on
this plane and it was like you just
drive your car
to the plane you drive right out on the
tarmac
i'm in shock you get out of your car you
take three steps you walk up into the
plane it takes off you land and when you
land your rental car is waiting at the
bottom of the steps i'm like holy crap
this is unbelievable there's food on the
plane there's a bathroom on the plane
it's like this is ridiculous this can't
be possible and i remembered that plane
and i remember thinking to myself
i'm buying one of these someday i'm
going to buy it after i hit certain
criteria after i saved enough after i
gave enough away i'm buying one of these
and i've chartered since then i've
probably phone phone mostly private i
don't know 10 years i don't i never talk
you never hear me talk about this look
at this some of us some of you i have a
relationship with for seven to ten years
never shared this because i don't that's
why i don't want you to respect me
because i got a big house and a plane i
want you to respect me for my heart my
feeling and how i got here that's what i
hope i hope i share that with you guys
you see a lot of people go on your
facebook right now i guarantee there's
somebody holding the half a million
bucks in their hand and someone else in
front of their lamborghini and someone
else showing off their watch right you
never see that with me i wear pretty
much a gray t-shirt today it's a very
special day i have a greenish gray shirt
on it's a special day right here i
digress i was on that plane probably 15
18 years ago
i bought that plane
a year ago but was it easy
no have i failed miserably yes have i
doubted myself absolutely have i felt
like an imposter more than you'll ever
know or ever believe
but it's possible
the only thing is we have to stay in the
game we have to find what drives us we
have to keep moving forward we have to
say to ourselves again i know so i see
so many incredible people on here i know
the success you've had this isn't about
you not having success success up until
now it's about me hopefully helping you
get to that next level of success and
listen
i'm at a place where i don't
like yes i have a plane i have the i
have a beautiful home
but i'm not flashy i don't i drive a
ford pickup truck by the way guys if you
lived in arizona and you saw me at a red
light i drive a white ford f-150 every
day i do not have any other car i don't
have motorcycles i don't buy watches i
have a really nice watch on my wrist
right now if you know watches it's one
of the nicest watches out there it was a
present from tony robbins from all the
work we do together or else i'd have a
simple little watch or not wear one at
all so i'm really simple in some areas
and then i get to do the things that i
want but i wouldn't do any of those
things that i want unless i could give
at the level i want to give
last year i donated more to charity than
ever before in my life
you have a dream you have a desire and
when you're a certain age you stop that
dream maybe you got serious about a job
and people put their arm around you and
said you're finally growing up i
appreciate your responsibility really
i just threw my dreams in the toilet and
you want to say you're proud of me but
it anchored that in oh that's the right
thing my parents my friends my teachers
one more time screw that
they did it because they thought they
were caring and loving you and that's
not it
you have to push past the fear listen
i don't i don't like to always use me as
an example let me just share matt larson
my top real estate students didn't go to
college got actually got thrown out of
college tried one semester they threw
him out didn't have any money grew up on
a farm
that not his farm his father managed
another farm in a little tiny rented
place worked on a farm went to be a
machine shop worker worked 70 hours a
week in a machine shop
lived in a 300 square foot apartment
did all the stuff i'm telling you got my
courses spent a lot of money on his
education and his family came to him and
said are you crazy real estate's for
rich people you'll never be able to do
it his girlfriend broke up with him
because he spent lots of money on the
education said you're a dreamer and he
was right he called us to literally give
everything back and we said did you even
try he's like no but
but all stories all fear all we said is
please go try it
that was like 3
500 real estate deals ago millions of
dollars generated lives change he's a
partner of mine he's a great dude he
went to a whole nother level he employs
70 people
do you know what almost killed him was
the fear of believing all the
for lack of better word he was told all
those years it wasn't the real estate
skills it wasn't the real estate market
it didn't mean that he wasn't because he
didn't go to college and he didn't have
money or he was in too small of a town
or too big of a city or too hot of a
market or there's no good deals or
banded signs.org had nothing to do with
that he almost quit because of the fear
of breaking through of listening to all
the crap
what about you
anything like that close ever happened
to you
of course it has you might be thinking
it right now dean you want me to write
down what i'm good at you want me to
write down what i like to do that's not
going to make me money that's not true
completely not true
i i was i had dyslexia i barely got out
of high school i was a car mechanic in
my 20s every day greasy hands and
painting cars and sucking in fumes if
somebody would have said yeah that car
mechanic in there that's all dirty with
his
mechanic outfit on he's going to write
multiple new york times best-selling
books he's going to be best friends with
tony robbins and richard branson he's
going to touch the lives of millions of
people
you see that guy no wait a minute you're
talking that guy over there the one
sucking paint fumes painting inside the
car never
right
so don't tell me wherever you are you
can't go to where you want to go i'm
giving you the keys i'm giving you the
principles i wish i wish i wish i wish
someone would have told me this stuff
earlier on it doesn't matter if you're
20 40 60 80 or 90
today's the day you could start today's
the day you could break through that
fear today's the day you can realize
what my vision is and how i can start
saying no to stuff so i can work on my
unique ability so i can go to that next
level do you want to know one of the
biggest secrets to sales in our world
today right now where i i believe where
we're at
is authenticity
people just want to know what's real
what's raw and they want it from your
heart
if you think about the people that
you've connected with in your life
remember this phrase
people will buy from you say yes to you
when they feel understood not just when
they understand you
don't you listen to that again people
will buy from you say yes to you when
they feel understood not just when they
understand you
let's take let's take an example then
i'm going to circle back around with
authenticity so i'm going to park
authenticity put a pin in it and come
back to it but think about this
think about let's just say the
quintessential sales area is used cars
or new cars and i know that world is
changing but let's just talk about uh
the way it was for the last 100 years 50
years
saturday afternoon your car shopping you
pull into the dealership there's 10
dealers waiting in the window waiting
for you to come in
you pull up
one of them gets a high five your turn
go go chat with the guy in the tesla or
whatever right
now think about this scenario same
scenario
person comes up
and says
hey glad glad you're here today nice
saturday right hey listen i just wanted
to let you know i've been selling these
cars for 27 years i know i'm inside and
out i've been voted the top sales guy 14
months out of the last five years
and it's because i care about the client
this is what i do and i can see
you're here today
and
you'd love us a sporty car but
let me guess
you want something that's a little good
on the gas maybe eco-friendly so you can
do your part i got this amazing
two-seater it's fast it's eco-friendly
it's this it's that let's go take a look
at
now that's a sales guy that could make a
job for 27 years and he wants you to
understand him
but what if
you went there that day
because you want you just had your third
child
and you want your wife to have something
that's not a minivan but the big suvs
are too clunky you're just looking for
something in the middle nothing even
close
now that same sales person wants you to
understand him what if there's a sales
person that comes out
and you see him walking over to you and
you're like oh [ __ ] here comes this
sales guy you roll down your window or
you get out
and he says hey listen first off i know
it's a saturday we all work on
commissions
authenticity transparency we all work on
commissions it's my turn up i gotta i
get you but i just want to tell you
let me just back up i just want to ask
why are you here today what's your
family like
what uh how can i serve you tell me a
little bit about you
and all of a sudden the person says wow
immediately who do you have rapport with
immediately
sales guy number two because he wanted
he wants you to feel understood and
probably not on purpose that's just who
he is all of a sudden you go well we had
our third kid and you oh my god i'm on
my fourth i get it my wife hated the
minivan when i thought about bringing it
to her house she was like are you crazy
but then i looked at the monster
escalating she's that's a bus
but we figured out something in between
would you be open to something kind of
in the middle it's kind of like the
sporty uh
smaller suv all of a sudden you're
laughing high-fiving talking about the
names of your kids what's going on in
school playing softball or baseball and
what they do and all of a sudden you're
sitting in the car going he's a good guy
and what did he do most of the time
he listened
he was authentic he was transparent you
cannot
create your compelling future until you
decide what your painful future is
because this will get you this is once
you get around here now all of a sudden
you're going up the loop like you
projected if i don't do crap i'll be
stuck right here
but now that i felt that way what would
be ideal what would be ideal
what's a compelling future for you
for me
in my relationship
tony i'm going to give my credit to my
boy tony
i've done all these things before but he
made me do it in front of him maybe go
in the other room and do it i took a
piece of paper when it comes to
relationships i made a line down the
middle and i put on the left side
what was an absolute must in the next
relationship i have and on the right
side i put absolute
unacceptable
and i literally wrote down things that
and i'm just being honest i i wrote down
everything i wrote down someone who
loves my children i know this would be
hard someone who will love my children
as if their own
someone who works on their personal
growth someone who's a go-getter someone
who knows that we're flawed and we're
all trying to get better i just wrote
down all these things that i was looking
for seemed like it was too good to be
true and i put what was not acceptable
someone doesn't have a big heart someone
won't accept my children someone wants
to fight with my ex or fight with other
people someone who likes confrontation i
won't accept anyone who doesn't you know
want to work on their health and their
growth i wrote all this stuff down
seemed crazy it was my compelling future
i stared at it and i looked at it and i
felt so good and it gave me my true
north
i projected being alone and staying the
way i was and i also wrote down a
compelling future i write down a
compelling future in my business all the
time i do things the way i want to do i
want to make my own rules i don't want
anybody to tell me how what kind of
husband i can be if i want to take off
the mill a day and romance my wife
because we have the most amazing
relationship in the world that might
sound boring to you or that sounds ugh
but that's me
i will fight for that i will die for
that that is my why being a leader to my
incredible team that's like my family
learning and growing and help impact the
world help unite us unlock arms so we
can help shift the world how do we
change the global economy by changing
the economy in our homes how do we
change the global conversation by
changing the conversation in our homes
we are the change we affect the change
no one's coming to fix it to me that's
my why i hope you can hear it i hope you
can feel it it comes from my heart
so when i'm standing on one side of the
ravine and i see where i want to go on
the other before i even know how i'm
gonna get in there i know my why and i'm
getting over there no matter what if i
gotta get bloody bruised up fail
whatever it takes i'm getting to the
other side
are you
do you know the true reason why you're
listening to this why you want another
level if you don't go find it
i promise you when you find it nothing
will stop you not a brick wall not a
steel girder not dirt a mount nothing a
mountain won't stop you when you know
your true why i just told a story
to a dear friend of mine that i haven't
shared in ages
and i always i look back at this story
it's the first time i ever made a
million dollars i was in my 20s it was
on a real estate deal
and i say that now a million dollars to
me then might as well been 200 billion
dollars um
but i look back and i wonder if i would
be as creative and as hungry now
as i was when i did that deal
because here's what i know is a lot of
times being successful has a lot to do
with being naive or not been told being
told been told no to where you start
believing what other people say to not
of watching the news for years so you
just want to play small or listen to
people tell you how now this isn't the
right time not the right president you
know all these things in life these
outside influences outside game affects
the inner game it makes you play small
without even realizing like every year
you just start playing smaller and
smaller well i was in my early 20s had
no money i mean when i say no money
nothing right just working hard i was
hustling cars i was fixing wrecked cars
and selling them
and this piece of property came for sale
um well it actually wasn't for sale it
came for sale because i became friends
with the owner his name was mark miller
he's a famous artist and he owned 28
acres of
vineyards because he owned a winery and
there was an old vineyard had the
grapevine still in it but the weeds had
grown up
and
everybody stayed away from this property
because he wanted a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars and all the neighbors
got so used to the property being vacant
that one guy shot his bow and hour he
practiced uh uh you know his hour for
archery hunting he practiced on the
property another guy had his
four-wheeler trail through the whole
thing another guy there was a barn on
the property one of the neighbors kind
of adopted the barn because it was kind
of vacant no one was around so he kind
of adopted the barn and used it and to
him it was his and the other guy up on
the hill just wanted complete privacy he
didn't want anybody building next to him
that's that's in real estate we call it
not in my backyard i could build a house
but i don't want anybody building in my
backyard right so everybody stayed away
from this property and plus he was
asking maybe a little bit too much but
mark miller and i the gentleman on the
property became friends and i made a
deal with him to give him 90 000 up
front and 90 000 um in two years or a
year or something like that
and i was going to subdivide this
property so i didn't have the 90 grand
back then and i told this story prior to
one of my uh clients and friend lent me
the money to buy the property i made him
a partner on it um so i went to mark
miller i locked up the property and i go
through the s now i'm sharing this story
specifically take the lessons out of it
is one of it was being naive and one of
his and i put this in my first real
estate course which was called think a
little different
because i want to encourage you to think
outside the box life paints you inside
life is forcing you in at all times we
go to school and they they give us time
frames and buzzers and bells and and
don't talk to anybody else and sit in
your square sit in your in your world
don't stray out don't i mean in in
business if you don't collaborate with
others you die but in school if you do
it's called cheating
makes zero sense to me it's like the
world is designed to put you in the box
and the only people who make it to live
at their full potential the ones who
break out of the box so i'm sharing this
story because
being naive being young and being
freaking hungry i mean i was hungry for
another level
there was nobody telling me no made this
a million dollar deal so by the property
i start going through the subdivision
process and i'm beg bar and steal i'm
hustling cars during the day to use the
money to pay for this subdivision i have
engineers and architects and now i got
to lay out the road i'm learning all
this stuff about a big subdivision it's
called a major subdivision i had done a
minor subdivision which was like three
lots or four lots or less so now i'm
doing a major and all of a sudden it
starts i go to the first planning board
meeting and all the neighbors show up
and they're just like like like i like i
murdered their children for lack of a
better word they just would despise me
and i'm like wow how am i gonna and you
gotta realize in business one person
upset
can stop or cause you years and i didn't
have the money to to drag this thing out
for years and fight the neighbors and
all that kind of stuff so
they go and one of the guys name was
wade sargent his mother and my mother
were best friends growing up so wade was
still there fighting me he didn't want
this subdivision to go in his backyard
so i walked to wade's house one day this
is being hungry this is being not afraid
to go after your dreams not taking no as
an answer when's the last time you gave
up too easy and someone else got their
dreams maybe with your idea
so i knock on wade's door and there was
wade sergeant i said hey wade what's up
idea it was kind of like you're my
friend but you're trying to ruin my
backyard uh so i said wade listen i'm
gonna make that subdivision happen it
might take me longer everybody can fight
me i'm gonna make it happen i don't give
up but how can i make you happy
and what he told me
changed everything he said well i just
really don't want the road to go close
to my backyard if i had a little buffer
he said i've had a little buffer i'd be
fine i'd support you i'm like well by
buffer you mean if i sold you a piece of
that property you'd be happy he said
yeah would you do that i said heck yeah
i'll take your money so i do a lot line
revision not even a subdivision you
don't have to know real estate to
understand this i did a lot line
revision and i gave him a half of an
acre and he cut me a check like wow i
went to all the neighbors the guy that
was using the barn like it was his
carved out an acre and sold him the barn
the guy that wanted privacy i sold him
four acres another guy wanted a two acre
cushion next door neighbor wanted to
sell some la i wanted to put a house for
his uh daughter on his property someday
i ended up selling
over 250 000
worth of lot line revisions to the
neighbors and all of them happy all of a
sudden all of them from hating me
everybody staying away from this
property they all love me i was the guy
going down the road they high-fived me
they waved to me and then guess what
then i subdivided the center piece of
property and sold the center for over
eight hundred thousand dollars
brought in over a million dollars on
this piece of property by making the
neighbors happy now people much smarter
than me developers in our town looked at
that property told me i was crazy uh uh
um
rick a affuso
his dad
um
told me because he had farmed that
property when he was a kid and i
respected him he was a great real estate
developer in our little town
and
um
he told me you paid 180 for that
property you just lost your butt you
didn't say but you just lost your ass he
said and um i was like damn it maybe i
did but they were all looking at it from
inside the box i was desperate i was
hungry i didn't take no for an answer
and i looked at it completely different
like the name of my first course think a
little different where in your life
right now are you inside the box and you
don't realize it and you need to think a
little different that's where change
happens that's where innovation happens
that's where breakthroughs happen that's
when people go holy crap how did he do
that how did she do that it's by not
taking no for an answer not
looking from looking at it through a set
of glasses that everybody has
everybody's got the same glasses on wear
a different pair look at things
differently go for it don't let the
world talk you into to being complacent
i'd love people to to really think about
is their thoughts
you have you ever read the untethered
soul no and so you got to put it on your
list it's a yeah i'm how about eckhart
tolle the power now sure yeah you read
that yes okay so an untethered soul is
for me it's it's that and and so much
more it's it's a great book
um so i know if you had another question
so i think so i i'll reframe that it's
that one but if there's one specific
question i'd love for people to say how
do you
be the observer of your thoughts
and that's something do you yeah and
that's something i would
i would i always like this is because
i've been obsessed with it for the last
three years because i want to be the
observer of thoughts immediately
and i'm not there yet i want it to
trigger because when you're having a bad
day an angst day a stressful day you
feel off or overwhelmed most the time
it's just the thoughts we're having in
that particular day
and when you can look back and view
those thoughts you can make a decision
to throw them out or not let that spin
you up or feel it for 10 minutes and
then throw it out but when you leave
them there
they just linger and the more i've
become aware of my thoughts
the more i've evolved as a person so
again i'm sitting here because my
daughter you're probably bored to death
on love you
uh she's doing great over there i'm
gonna tell a story about her
i am trying to observe my thoughts as
they happen
so i don't know if she'll remember this
but we were
we were and i'm sharing this is my story
but i want you to put yourself in these
shoes this could be your husband your
wife your kids your co-worker your
partner people you do business with
employer employees but we're at
breakfast and breakfast is really
important to our family we have
breakfast every single day and and i
cook for them most of the time and
so we sit at breakfast and try to have
conversations about gratitude and all
this kind of stuff and
my son brody was obsessed with these
crayons and they were like these crazy
colors they weren't red they were like
aqua blue marine something
so i'm sitting there using them and
and i pull it out oh god this is a cool
color and he names it i'm telling us for
a reason so i pull out another he names
all i was at 25 or 50 in that pack so he
names all of them these big long names
i'm like dude what an incredible gift i
couldn't memorize these if i spent a
month trying that's not my how my brain
things but that's him he's this
structured organized kid so brie
she says to me i could do that so i
don't know if you remember this one but
she studied it and like five minutes
late on the second one she didn't
remember i'm like we're all blessed with
different gifts i couldn't remember he
does that but my daughter is the
inventor she comes up with ideas that
are real not not kid invention she's
going to be a mate she's going to be the
visionary my son's going to be the
implementer if she ever read rocket fuel
that's the two kids i have
implementer and a visionary right
so when she tried all of a sudden she
got upset and started almost crying and
she said
because there's so much attention going
to my son of course and she says dad
it's because you spend more time with
brody than me in the mornings
and i remember
just having the immediate thought that
may have came from my dad or the way i
was brought up and i said to her breed
don't lie to me and don't lie to
yourself that's not true
i i work my butt off to be completely
equal and you're telling yourself a lie
it's not a good story and i went on this
rant and she tucked it up she stopped
tears she tucked up it was the first
time ever that she left the house
without kissing me goodbye
ever and i'm like well she just got to
learn that lesson yeah and she left for
about a half hour
and i
like it hit me like a ton of bricks like
i observed that thought i had and what i
basically told my daughter is that i
didn't give a [ __ ] about her feelings
that it didn't matter how she felt right
that dad was right tuck it down i said
if she was married to a man and i
watched her try to tell her husband
about her feelings how she was feeling
and he basically told her to shut up and
tuck it down i'd have a talk with that
dude right if he's married to my
daughter and i treated my daughter that
way i got in my car because i only
because i'm sharing this because i
practice trying to observe what's going
on why am i feeling this way what is
this thought i'm having step back look
at it when i stepped back and looked at
i knew i screwed up i drove to school
100 miles an hour even if you were right
even if i was right now
i might have been right that i keep
equal time yes but i didn't acknowledge
her feelings exactly i didn't
acknowledge your feelings i mean that's
the gift of selling it's not what people
need it's what they want how they feel
right so i told her her feelings i drove
to her school 100 miles an hour you were
at chapel remember i came and got you
out of chapel i got her out of chapel
and i walked her outside and i said dad
screwed up i said i may have been right
in context but i wasn't right and
telling you your emotions mean something
your feelings mean something and we had
a great talk we hugged we kissed her and
i had the best relationship in the world
and
and i left and i felt amazing and she
felt amazing and i never would have
caught that
if i wasn't observing my thoughts so i
say that story about my family my
daughter who's sitting here right now
but who
who are you not you know what thoughts
are clouding your judgment in a marriage
or in a relationship or in your
partnership or trying to get a raise or
taking your life to another level
whatever it is in your life most of the
time it's those thoughts
that are messing with us and if you can
you can observe them you can adjust them
and something i just always love saying
is because it really affected me when i
was young stop trying to get good at the
things you suck at too i just i need to
say that because it's the biggest lie
we've ever been told it dings our
confidence with i still can't read if i
if i wrote you two sentences in an email
half the words would light up misspelled
and some of them are so bad that i try
three different times to spell it and
the computer can't even like if i could
talk to maybe like idiots like what are
you trying to say i have no freaking
clue what you're saying and then i just
put like good you know
i completely related so but what it does
is what let me just ask you
watching or listening right now if
you're
if you work on something you suck at
does it make you feel empowered does it
make you feel like you wanna like me
trying to do accounting like you could
never do it it's not my personality so
what i know about the most successful
people on the planet including you ed
you just got really great at a few
things correct the things that light you
up the things that inspire you and when
that fire starts you can't stop it and
eventually you'll pay someone to do the
things you suck at maybe you can't
afford that now but just don't don't let
anybody give you a bill of goods on on
working on the things trying to get
better at what you're failing no just go
get great at a few things yeah i wish i
could debate you on that but i can't
because i 100 agree do you ever have
something where it immediately boiled
your blood immediately made you
made you feel pissed like like anger or
adrenaline rushed through and not in a
good way not positive adrenaline a lot
of times that happens when you know
someone took advantage of you you know
sometimes that happens when people lie
to you like blatantly lie to you or
someone causes something when you knew
it was gonna happen like please don't do
that please don't do that they do it and
it breaks or it changes or the
relationship is over the business
doesn't work or someone robs money from
you
i don't know maybe you're thinking right
now maybe somebody took advantage of you
by being unfaithful in the relationship
yeah this is millionaire success habits
podcast but all of these things lead to
a successful life and that's why i want
to share each and every one of you
each and every one of you i want to
share this with because we got to get it
like this stuff's got to stick to us we
don't get this by reading one book or
what listening to one podcast or
watching one video we gotta live this
[ __ ]
for lack of a better word we gotta stop
screwing around we gotta
implement this and be a part of our life
so reason i'm sharing this this morning
i bought a piece of property 20
something years ago i'll just tell you
the story at 30 000 feet so i buy this
property 20 probably 20
i don't know 24 years ago 26 years ago
crazy long time ago i bought it with
someone and since then they kind of
bailed out little piece of property not
millions of dollars smaller piece of
property but anyway long story short
they bailed out don't pay the taxes
don't pay the insurance and then the so
i've been paying it for years um
now this has been 20 something years the
property's been sitting there and i just
had it for too long it's time to just
i'm gonna unload it and sell it to a
friend at a huge discount about a third
of what i've paid for the taxes over the
year and the insurance on the property
right
so i reach out to the
uh half owner and all i said was hey you
know what we got this property i'm
selling it to a friend just so i have to
pay the taxes on it if you want it you
could surely have it take over the taxes
um but i'm just going to dump it so
could you sign off on it
no reply no reply finally i get a reply
this morning it's like well how much
could i get out of it what kind of money
could i get and after all these years of
not saying anything
and all these years of other
circumstances where i went above and
beyond for this person years and years
ago to help out
that's what i got now i'm literally
in my car before i go and i'm looking at
text messages just moments ago
and i got furious like it hit me like
maybe it's old feelings like maybe being
picked on when i was little because i
was small or
or you know just something hit my ego
something hit my brain i was pissed i'm
like
i wanted to reply back like what the f f
do you mean like all that i've done paid
all the taxes all the other things all
i'm asking is to stop the bleeding or
you could even have the property if you
want it
and that's the reply get not hey thanks
for covering the taxes and insurance for
all those years sorry i haven't brought
anything up sorry i didn't contribute
but guess what
here's what i realized
i got mad for probably that that
something like that could have made me
mad 20 years ago for a week i could have
been about it i could have told my
friends about it i said oh you don't
believe what's happening to me so my
first reply was a bit snarky like not
super sarcastic i'm like well then i'm
done you can have it i take the property
i'll sign it off to you and i was i
almost sent another one like
what the f man like why would you and
then i thought about it and i said
the only person that's hurting is me
i'm gonna film a bunch of videos today
i'm at my studio i just pulled in my
office i'm at my studio it's 8 24 am as
i'm recording this for you
and i'm gonna go in and film videos for
three hours on a training that i
freaking love it's going to be so
awesome you guys i'll get access to it
you'll see it and some new podcasts
if i let that bug me that's going to
screw up how i effect positively affect
you if i let that bug me it's going to
throw my day off if i let that bug me
i'm going to not be the same dad to my
kids when they come home from school
today i'm not going to be the same
person it's going to throw me off guess
what
the other person
nothing's going to change for them the
only person that's going to negatively
impact by me getting pissed is me
because can i make them act a different
way am i am i in charge of their
emotions am i in charge of the way they
feel and i thought maybe they're going
through something maybe they're
financially strapped maybe they're
fighting with their spouse or their
loved ones and and i just sat this all
happened literally in moments i'm
sitting in the car ready to send a wise
ass remark reply and i said if i send
this
only person is hurting me i'm going to
be off today i won't shoot my videos
i'll start thinking why would they do
this to me i'm such a good guy in this
situation i went over and above and and
people take advantage of me then i'll
start thinking who else has taken
advantage of me and who else just
screwed me over and why is that
happening and is my accountant doing the
right job is my secretary doing a good
job that's the path we can go down
am i perfect hell no i screw this [ __ ]
up all the time
but i just sat
and i sat i erased the reply i was gonna
send and i sent one back and said okay
no worries i'll handle it um i hope
things are well with you have a great
day
and best wishes on all you do
and i sent it and it was done
it was it was literally done
the the
anger i felt the didn't take an
advantage feeling ahead it was all done
it was out and it was gone
and
let me ask you what are you holding on
to right now that's hindering your
success you want millionaire success
habits let go of the stuff that's
holding you back let go of the stuff
that builds resentment let go of the
stuff that allows you not to trust
anybody let go of the stuff that's
stopping you from great relationships
let go of the stuff that's stopping you
from having a partnership let go of the
stuff that keeps you afraid of going on
and venturing out to do your own thing
it's only hurting you there's probably
not much i'm sharing today you haven't
heard before you've read it in books
you've heard it someplace you've watched
a video or a podcast but what i'm going
to ask you to do for the first time is
actually listen and apply it
and that's that's been my mission lately
is like i know there's some of the
things success principles are the same
since the beginning of time
but when is it time to stop being
inspired stop just watching ed and start
just doing what ed does like when is
that time to stop looking for the next
hit of a great podcast the next hit of
watching tony or dean or ed or andy or
somebody watching feeling good and then
going back to the same routine what if
this was the time what if this was the
interview what if this was the moment
you said i'm not just going to listen
i'm going to start to do i remember in
my own life when i started getting
success i was working my guts out i was
working on cars during the day
i was working at real estate at night
and then then
one before i did my first like education
course
i was doing cars during the day real
estate at night and send me alarm at
five in the morning from five to like
nine in the morning i'd work on trying
to figure out how to write a course on
how to do what i did in my life and how
to be successful i was so confused
i did all that and guess what i did that
for years for years i'm just being
honest i put in lots and lots of hours i
had fun i enjoyed myself i played hard
too but i put in a lot of time
but then when it finally hit and i got a
little momentum
you know i heard a lot of my friends say
oh you lucky bastard
in fact i had a joke for a while made me
think i had a joke for a while but when
i try something new that's out of the
norm which most people wouldn't try
people either say oh you dean got lucky
you lucky bastard or if i tried and
failed it's like i knew that idiot
wouldn't make it there's nothing in
between and you know what
awesome screw it i don't care i don't
dislike my friends who said all that
stuff i'm still friends with them some
of them says fifth grade
but they're going to look through life
through a lens of
they're satisfied with okay they're
satisfied making okay money they're
satisfied with okay relationship they're
satisfied with being an okay parent
they're satisfied with an okay career
that doesn't light them up screw that
i'm not satisfied with i'd rather fail
miserably if i look back on my death bed
would you you too let me ask you would
you let him look back on your deathbed
and be like hey you know what played it
safe didn't go after anything but you
know i lived an okay life
[ __ ] that excuse my language i it just i
felt like saying it and i said it and if
you have someone younger listen i'm
sorry i feel bad now but that's the
emotion i feel and if you're listening
to me if you're listening to my podcast
then you feel the same way i just was
having this girl a conversation with my
girlfriend lisa
and we were talking about uh the things
that drive you and the things that um
that want to be
you know it's funny you say like i have
so many different emotions at once
but
she comes from an amazing family just
like you said your wife did yeah like
amazing she has there's five siblings
their parents are together they're on a
text string every day they all talk
every day like her phone's always
blowing up and going off and it's always
inspirational and they're they all
support each other one just lost their
job and their whole family's like well
get together it's finally time you start
your own business anyway and i'll build
the website i'll give you the money like
it's unbelievable what they do and i
love both my parents my mom and dad are
amazing but i didn't have that they
split at three
i was three when they split and i lived
with mom and then dad and graham and
they moved you know i moved 20 times by
the time i was 19. right so all this
insecurity so but again that was my
journey made me the man i am so for me
one of the things
is that i don't have something to refer
to to be a good dad
my father's father
physically abused all the kids they were
some were sexually abused and his father
did that i think i look at this long
lineage of
screwed up graziosis and i knew it was
going to stop with me
like my sister did it she's an amazing
mother
actually my nephew works for me
incredible kids like the greatest kid
you ever met she stopped it and i want
to do the same thing so i'm always in
like you and i when we talk later we'll
probably just talk about being a parent
because i love interviewing and talking
to other great parents because i want to
learn because i don't have a blueprint
like i said lisa she's got the blueprint
she grew up from it right so for me i
want to be a better man and always want
to continue to grow so i can set an
example and change
the way my kids
see life and experience life i don't
want to raise entitled brats that's the
last thing this world needs um i want
them to have hunger and drive and be
good people and and one thing i'll share
with you
a dear friend of mine
he's about 15 years older than me he
said to me
and he's done extremely well just
extremely well and he said
i think at the end of our lives
when you're on your deathbed
i don't think we'll ask any other
question because you're a parent like me
he says your dad like me i could see it
because i think the question we're going
to ask ourselves is did we do everything
we could
to give our kids the the tools to live a
fulfilled life i said i mean because i
don't think anything you won't say how
many women did i sleep with how much
money did i make how many buildings that
i buy it'd be like wow did i give the
kids and i said he said you'll be able
to go off to the next place if you could
say yes you did your best because but
what if you can't say that
and for me it's like that's all i think
about it's like that's one of the things
i i can't be the perfect i try i do
everything i can to be a great dad just
like you but fundamentally i want to
give them the tools to be thriving
adults
and that's just one i mean yeah that i
could talk about that i want to go
conquer something right now thinking
about that people will buy from you and
learn from you when they feel understood
not when they understand you do you hear
that that's one of the biggest secrets
to my success people will buy from you
do business from you with you learn from
you when they feel understood not when
they understand you most people want to
just
vomit up all their experience vomit up
on how good they are vomit up on how
great their product is and you don't
even know what the person on the other
side is thinking think about that with
salesman would you do you like a pushy
salesman when you go to buy a car that
comes out and says i've been doing this
for 30 years i got this i got this
experience this little baby be perfect
for you it's fast it's quick it's it's a
two-seater it's this this this and he
doesn't realize you showed up because
you want an suv because you have four
kids like wouldn't have been better if
you just walked out and said hey man out
looking for a car what's up with your
family what do you got going on and just
listened people buy from you when they
feel understood when there's a
connection i listen to people all the
time and they're always telling me their
old story yeah you know they're just
they live and they don't know a story
and they don't know we don't know it but
the just the concept of a story overall
that we tell ourselves you talk you
speak about that probably more
eloquently than anybody that i've heard
so just touch on the whole concept of
the cognizance of the story we tell
ourselves yeah so i think i mean even
with me like i said i had to catch
myself i was telling myself a story that
maybe i should have stayed with the real
estate brand maybe success there's so
many people deluding it that haven't had
the success they don't recognize the
real thing like i i had all kinds of
stories i'd look at people like god that
guy seems like a scammer why has he got
three million followers like i started
telling myself stuff yeah and i felt bad
and i wasn't having the momentum that i
know how to create and then all of a
sudden i changed that story and i said
no i know what i want to do for people
i'm the freaking best at it there's
nobody better than me give me a year
i'll be far surpassed and then they'll
realize they're actually learning from
someone who's done it and nothing
changed god didn't come down the weather
didn't change my bank account didn't
change there's nothing changed except my
story so so the part that i want to
share is
i did a uh i did an interview with a
young kid casey adams
yeah so casey so he asked me a great kid
and he said hey man at the end maybe he
asked you he said you were as a young
kid there's a lot of young kids
listening what would be the one thing
that you would tell people and i'd never
been asked that i and literally what
just came out is
that
your thoughts lie to you
and to question those thoughts
because when i look back at what stalled
me or almost had me fail or the people
around me it had nothing to do with
who's president whether you like the
president or not if he's crazy or not
the economy or your family your friends
holding you down a job that takes too
much time it's never any of that the
only thing standing between you and your
next level a better version of you not
not being me not being not just a better
version of the only thing and you might
not believe me right now but i promise
you someday you will the only thing
standing between you and your next level
better version of you is the story you
tell yourself and why you can't get it
that's it so good
i mean i think about it i remember
having a real estate deal when i was
broke and it's a million dollar deal and
i got four bucks in the bank number
saying i'll never get this money i'll
never and i never could and all of a
sudden i'm like no screw that i'm
getting this money and i would find it
it didn't matter if i had to beg borrow
steal
you know some of the banks some on
credit cards borrowing from this guy i'd
make the deal happen when nothing else
changed i didn't inherit money i didn't
get smarter my iq didn't go up i didn't
have a harvard education
i just willed it by changing the story
so i guess an easy way for you guys to
think about right now if you talk about
what you would where you would love to
be it's a year from now it's the
greatest year of your life and you'd
love to be there i'd love to be
you know working on my own on my own
company i'd love to to launch my own
company i'd like to have more time with
my wife or my husband and my kids just
say but
and then fill in whatever that butt is
that's usually your story but my boss
keeps me my boss keeps me too busy but
my wife doesn't support me but my family
thinks i'm crazy but i'm not that smart
but it takes money to make money that's
your story that's the thing that's your
anchor you're dragging across the desert
flip that story and immediately that
becomes the wind behind your sail i mean
i don't want to oversimplify it but at
this phase of my life it is
oversimplified
and i still run into it i will catch
myself being in a [ __ ] space worried
about something worried about some of my
kids worrying about anything and i'm
like why is this bugging me why is this
oh because i'm telling myself lies i'm
telling myself some stuff i change it
and then i change in a second i screwed
up in my marriage my ex screwed up we
both screwed up we we admit our faults
we admit where we ignored the wrong
things we pushed things off so far it
was too late by the time we wanted to
fix it with all the good i've done with
all the positivity i i
messed up and and i can admit that and i
hope that you can admit where we mess up
we do but how do i honor those mistakes
by never making them again i will never
make the same mistakes i give my ex the
most respect love i'm still her family
she still got my back i still got hers
we still are going to make sure the kids
are first
and i see another level of life for me
and my kids beyond anything i could ever
imagine if you
know the product you have the service
you have the love that you have the
person you are if you know it's
authentic it's real it's the best on the
planet then you have to do everything in
your power to get people to take action
i say this all the time but the movie
field of dreams with kevin costner years
ago they said if you build it they will
come they won't come
they just won't
there's outliers that every once in a
while somebody builds something that
goes viral but most of the time when you
see a product that's working you see
someone who's evolving through a company
has a great relationship it's because
they know how to be persuasive they know
how to sell but i want to teach you two
things today there are emotional buyers
and there are logical buyers and if you
are just attracting one or the other
then you're doing everyone a disservice
so think about an emotional purchase
if you ever watched an infomercial if
you ever bought that tiny little hose
that is like this big it's a tight you
know it could fit in your hand and when
you
plug it in and you turn the weave screw
it on you turn the water on it gets 50
feet long right when you see something
like that an emotional you make an
emotional decision you got two minutes
like that hose looks great and you buy
it that's it that's an extreme example
and maybe it sits in your garage you
never use it i guarantee there are
things in your life you bought making an
emotional decision that's okay we need
emotions to move us forward so some
people are not i don't want to say this
in a bad way but some people are
rational buyers i'm an irrational buyer
from the top looking down when i see
something i like if i go buy a new car
if i walk on the dealership i see the
car but i like i want to leave there in
25 minutes with that car i'm irrational
i'm emotional if i'm if i'm watching a
video online or i'm at a live event and
i see something i like there's zero i'm
not waiting to
research my heart tells me it's good my
gut instinct tells me i'm good i'm
buying it so i am an emotional
irrational buyer but that's only a small
percent of the world then i'm on the
extreme of i'll do it right now i make
quick decisions on the complete other
extreme are buyers who have to be
extremely logical that means
if this sounds good this car looks good
but i'm going to go home i'm going to
research it i'm going to ask anybody i
know if they have a car like that i'm
going to go check the rating i'm going
to see how many miles per gallon it gets
i'm going to see if there's any flaws is
there any recalls and some people will
will just do that logical searching all
the way so that's the extreme so what i
want to share with you today
is when you're selling anything when
you're persuading someone it doesn't
matter again if it's getting a promotion
from your boss it's making more money
it's selling your product or service i
want you to think of
of attracting and fulfilling both of
them you need to get people emotional
people don't make decisions without
being emotional be connected feel moved
have a feeling inside but then if you
cover the logical part for those that
want to overthink then you can really
compound and exponentially grow your
sales so for example this past weekend i
was at an event and i spoke on stage and
i offered a 16 000 mastermind incredible
training worth every dime there were the
irrational emotional buyers like me who
took action immediately i would have
taken action halfway through the
presentation but then there were some
people who waited
until the second day and some people
that are very logical waited until the
third day last minute right before they
walked out the door and the sales were
about equal the emotional and the
logical but here's the thing i want you
to be careful of in your own life
make sure you don't get so logical and
need every eye dotted and every t
crossed that you never make a decision
you never pull the trigger every year
like i'm gonna i should have i would
have it's because you're you probably
have beliefs from parents beliefs from
teachers that you need to research that
you need to look before you leave i have
the i have the thoughts of
jump out of the plane grow wings on the
way down because he who hesitates loses
so two things i want to share if you're
selling if you want to fuel your company
your life you want to persuade people
remember some people make emotional some
people make logical decisions merge the
two together sales will increase in your
own life don't get so logical that you
missed out on amazing opportunities if
you are listening to this podcast you're
listening to other podcasts that
motivate you give you capabilities to go
faster quicker make more money have more
freedom control in your life all those
types of things but none of it listen to
me listen to this clearly maybe for the
first time in your life really hear me
none of it is possible if your
confidence is down
so i want you to think about the things
in your life
that steal your confidence and remember
when i say steal your confidence i don't
mean that you have a hundred percent of
confidence and you do something and you
go to 20 or 10 percent i'm talking about
when your confidence is off just five
percent do you make smart decisions when
your confidence is down do you go after
the business do you ask for the money do
you start the the website do you do you
uh get the girl do you get the promotion
do you ask your boss for a raise then
when your confidence is down you that's
when you start saying well maybe this is
good enough maybe my relationship is
good enough i should just be happy with
what i got i should just be happy with
the money i make screw that if you were
happy you wouldn't be here you'd be
doing something else right now besides
listening or watching me so let's just
face the facts where you are right now
is not sufficient for you doesn't mean
it's horrible but it's not enough
and if you want to get to that next
level you need to protect your
confidence
by any shape measure or form protect it
so what are the things that dig your
confidence i realized
at an early early time it's probably
been 10 years
that watching the news for me when i
watch the news and i see that it looks
like the world is going to hell in a
hand basket or what the president is
saying today or what congress is saying
or you listen to the left or the right
or or people in the middle if you listen
to all the gun violence and all like all
the news does for me is make me question
where the world is going in my next
level so for 10 years now i've been on a
news diet i don't watch the news i have
no clue what's going on nor do i care it
was the biggest transformation in my
life
i where i want to spend my time i want
to spend time with my family the people
i love my kids my team members they
deserve the best of me they don't
deserve dean 95 confidence they deserve
a hundred percent and if i watch the
news it it brings it down so i won't be
the best team leader i won't be the best
father i won't be the best man i can be
i won't be the best uh inspiration for
you so screw the news it dings my
confidence it's out i've been on a news
diet i challenge you to do the same
thing for me i don't know about you but
if if you have your phone i'm recording
on my phone here i'm stopped now i can
talk to you um but i don't know this is
my wallet but if you ever look at your
phone if it dings someone texts you or
calls you and you look at you go oh
should i answer this now
should i answer it later to me that robs
my confidence i don't want those people
in my life i either have to set
boundaries or have to push them out of
my life
listen let's just be honest stop feeling
bad for other people stop dimming your
glow stop talking about your
aspirational next level stop fantasizing
about your dreams in front of people
because it may insult them or make them
feel inferior or they may tell you
you're a dreamer if that's the case push
them out of your life or become teflon
and don't listen to their
people with unsuccessful businesses also
take opinions from the wrong people they
take advice from your parents advice
from your friends after at a picnic
advice from people who pretend they know
what they're doing their co-workers if
someone's not playing the game at the
highest level possible do not listen to
them if someone tried and failed don't
listen to them because they only know
how to do it wrong but people do all
these things they focus their energy
they want to make more money they focus
their energy on the wrong
on the wrong areas they focus on the
products the color they focus on the
logos they focus on the location or what
their website should look like and all
this obsessive stuff that means nothing
at the end of the day they try to create
something that people need and people
don't buy something unless they want it
and then when it's not working or before
they launch they ask an unqualified
person and then you wonder why your
business doesn't work and you feel like
you're stuck at a job or stuck in a
business that's not paying you anything
if you have your own business and you're
working 40 60 80 hours a week and making
less than you can in a job then you just
built yourself a job you don't have your
own business your next level of life
lives on the other side of your biggest
worry your biggest fear your biggest
obstacle and i can only say it by going
through it as i i'm repeating myself
because i want to hammer this home
face it deal with it fix it and watch
how much you grow i can honestly say i'm
in a place right now that i'm blessed
that i went through it i'm a better
version of me the mistakes i made i'll
never make again and the next level of
life is just an inch away from me
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want to see the
one-on-one i did recently with dean
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there the world
needs it let's do it we don't shift our
mindset nothing changes let's break the
internet again let's do it again